hi I'm Erik Bosse and with the guardians
of the galaxy playing such a big role in
the recent Avengers infinity war
guardians director James Gunn has been
even more active than usual on Twitter
which is really saying something
lean in on theories about his movies and
how they connect to infinity war
recently he reminded us that there's
still one big easter egg hidden
somewhere in the first guardians of the
galaxy it's there it's already been
partially uncovered so you just need to
find the whole thing man James Gunn's
really knows how to work up us nerds
what is this ready player one you know
what you can keep your Easter egg Jimmy
we got better things to do like God what
the hell is it we have done a Guardians
the galaxy Easter egg breakdown on this
channel before you may have seen Sam's
excellent video but coming through the
movie again some more interesting little
nuggets begin to pop up along with a
theory that might just might be what gun
is referring to so let's dive in a-holes
okay right off the bat quill realizes is
one nightstand beretta is still in the
ship and the shirt she's wearing it's
the same summer camp t-shirt that the
younger Peter was wearing on the day he
got abducted later on on Xandar during
Stanley's cameo the data on rocket
screen shows an alien language this
translates to Excelsior Stanley's
catchphrase and it's written in the
scroll language this is the first
appearance of the scroll and the MCU
they're an alien race that'll apparently
have a bigger role in the upcoming
Captain Marvel movie also during the
sequence he may have spotted these tall
figures wearing cloaks some wondered if
these could be the watchers the godlike
beings as Stanley was hanging out with
in the scene and guardians of the galaxy
vol 2
but James Gunn has debunked this he said
that these figures are just nuns after
the Guardians get arrested the
processing lineup gives us lots of
on-screen trivia about each character
most of which Sam has already gone
through but here are a couple other ones
I found interesting Gamora is listed as
the last survivor of her people these Z
hope Barrett Barry the CEO break Zeos
all Barry's which is interesting because
an Infinity Ward Thanos only killed half
of her people now let's be clear
guardians was written and shot years
before infinity war Gunn had no way of
knowing what they would end up doing
with her backstory and infinity war but
it's just worth pointing out that
Dennis's gesture to save this race from
self extinction by thinning the herd
didn't really work out too well for them
meanwhile quills profile has
a few little tidbits it was his name as
spacelord a joke about how Roman didn't
really take the name star-lord seriously
star Prince it also lists a translator
implant in his neck explaining how quill
can communicate in other languages and
in his criminal record it lists one
count of illegal manipulation of grim
ocean Duchess Gunn explained that quill
had gotten seduced by agra motion
royalty figure which apparently is a
crime group oceans are an alien race in
Marvel Comics they've fought against
Thor and they've shown up here and there
and speaking of all their criminal
records the jumpsuits that they and all
the prisoners in the kiln have to wear
have these barcodes on the legs these
bars correspond to the number and types
of crimes that they've committed with
black for murder and other colors for
crimes like arson and burglary now it's
possible that Rockets could be the
missing Easter egg quill stares at his
cybernetic implants and rocket alludes
to his tortuous backstory
now both Gamora and nebula were also
enhanced with similar painful implants
leading to this theory that rocket could
be another one of the children of Thanos
another theory came from the later scene
with rocket in the collectors space with
a small animal spine on the table beside
him perhaps suggesting that rocket could
have been an experiment by the collector
but Gunn has debunked that theory as
well the killin includes a few cameos
including this due to heckles Gamora as
they enter this is Lloyd Kaufman a
longtime screenwriter and director in
mentor to James Gunn later in nowhere
there's this sweet moment where Groot
produces a flower for a little girl this
is a nod to the classic film
Frankenstein when the monster befriends
a little girl by the lake and she gives
them this nice flower fortunately that
seems much worse for that girl now one
of the most fascinating new Easter eggs
to emerge from this movie comes from the
moment the collectors building gets
destroyed by the Power Stone check out
this wide exterior shot of the building
if you look closely it looks like James
Gunn snuck in nods to each of the six
original Avengers now the clearest one
is Thor's hammer Mjolnir right in the
middle there then if you look in the
upper right corner appears to be a
window that looks kind of like Iron
Man's arc reactor and then over in the
upper left is another window with
concentric circles that look a lot like
Captain America's shield in the bottom
left there's a radioactive symbol that's
commonly associated with the Hulk and
then to the
right of the big hammer there's a
spiderweb patterned rooftop with a red
light similar to black widows logo and
then the purple light of the Power Stone
lights up the building edifice in a way
that looks kind of like Hawkeye's purple
arrow logo this details awesome and this
could be what Gunn was referring to but
James Gunn has also been in a back and
forth with the youtuber MT over this
missing Easter egg for a long time
empties videos are fantastic I highly
recommend this guy he once theorized
that the Power Stone in the staff of the
celestial isang searcher in the
collectors Infinity stones backstory
explanation was egg-shaped and that it
could be a cosmic egg which is a super
powerful object that gets created in the
aftermath of the Infinity Gauntlet
events in the comics not worth going too
deep into it because James Gunn has
debunked this theory along with all of
empty's other theories unfortunately but
he has singled out MT as someone who's
gotten very very close to this Easter
Egg now to me this suggests that empty
may at least be right about this missing
Easter egg being an actual egg somewhere
in the movie so while I was thinking
about this I started to remember the
guardians of the galaxy volume 2
breakdown on this channel I made a year
ago in my analysis of the visuals of
that movie I pointed out the recurring
biological and reproductive imagery in
the movie specifically the egg shape and
the color palette of ego ship and the
design of the tableau that he later uses
to explain quills origin story now my
interpretation was that this reflected
the movies family theme with Peter torn
between his biological roots and the new
family he has formed with the Guardians
as he feels the pressure to as the
movies recurring Fleetwood Mac anthem
suggests never break the chain with one
chain being the biological bloodline and
the other chain being this new family
tie that he has now the time I presented
that as some like armchair film school
analysis that I found interesting but
then check this out comment on the video
now I'm not sure how YouTube's
verification works but I think that's
James Gunn himself saying nice if so
cool maybe we're onto something with
this egg as reproductive imagery stuff
now if you look at the first Guardians
closely maybe even a little obsessively
the shape of the DNA double helix starts
to pop up everywhere on all of their
criminal profiles the shape of Ronan's
Kree warship on the wall behind the sand
are barter ER and maybe it's me but even
those prisoner barkow
on their legs look kind of like the base
pairs that connect nucleotide strands of
DNA now others have suggested that this
DNA imagery could be a reference to Dan
Abnett and Andy Lanning comic writers
and artists who worked on the Nova
comics and are credited for creating the
new more popular version of star-lord in
the mid-2000s that the MCU adaptation is
based on dan and Andy go by the nickname
DNA nan to the artists who made all this
possible couldn't be the Easter Egg that
gun has been hinting at but I think the
DNA imagery could be connected with the
way the egg imagery was used in
guardians vol 2 as a metaphor for family
biology and reproduction
remember Gunn suggested that people have
only uncovered parts of the easter egg
but not the whole thing
maybe these movies as a whole are Easter
eggs specifically one egg and stages of
development it begins as all eggs do DNA
in the first stage and then into an egg
in the second stage and then in the
third stage guardians of the galaxy vol
3 the egg will hatch some new life form
could emerge what will that be well
maybe this perfect little egg baby we
saw incubating at the very very end of
volume 2 Adam warlock no you're reading
too much into this look guys until
Trains good confirms the correct egg
finding I will throw it over to you do
you think this is easier egg even exists
or is God just trolling us into watching
his movies over and over again wait a
minute
troll troll troll good god it was there
all along comment with your theories
down below or you can tweet me directly
at ESO ellos nos on Twitter for updates
on our videos like it share this video
and subscribe you new rock stars for all
of our deep dives and analysis of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe you check out
my full movie breakdown the guardians of
the galaxy vol 2 or Sam's rewatching the
first guardians and all the crap were
putting out on infinity war thanks for
watching guys bye
[Music]